Під публікацією DW у Фейсбук про те, як Зеленський "забув" задекларувати до НАЗК
понад 5 мільйонів гривень доходу від продажу облігацій, читач запитує:
"А як в цивілізованих країнах в таких випадках роблять?"
Приміром, німецькі політики йшли у відставку через найменшу брехню,
плагіат, приховування доходів тощо.
Найгучнішим корупційним скандалом останніх років у Німеччині став випадок
з федеральним президентом Крістіаном Вульффом.
Таблоїд "Більд" у 2011-му розкопав, що Вульфф начебто відпочивав
за рахунок знайомого бізнесмена.
Йшлося про 400 євро оплати за готельну кімнату.
Скандал набув розголосу, коли Вульфф подзвонив у редакцію газети
та у жорсткій формі зажадав припинити публікацію матеріалів, які його компрометують.
Як наслідок - звинувачення у тиску на пресу та відставка президента.
Суд згодом зняв з Вульффа звинувачення у корупції.
У політику експрезидент вже не повернувся.
Однак продовжує отримувати почесну пенсію - майже чвертьмільйона євро на рік.
Це засуджують 84 відсотки німців.
Головний скандал дев'яностих у Німеччині пов'язаний з колишнім канцлером Гельмутом Колем
та незадекларованими пожертвами для партійної каси.
Коли у 1999 році стало відомо, що низка функціонерів Християнсько-демократичного союзу
таємно отримали 1 мільйон дойчмарок від виробника озброєнь Schreiber,
ймовірно за сприяння у продажу танків до Саудівської Аравії,
Коль спочатку все спростовував. Але події розвивалися миттєво.
Менш ніж за місяць від початку скандалу Коль визнав,
що негласно прийняв 2 мільйони дойчмарок для партійної каси,
не провівши цю "пожертву" через партійну бухгалтерію, як того вимагав закон.
Від кого були ці кошти, Гельмут Коль відмовився сказати
з посиланням на "чесне слово", яке дав спонсорам.
Славетний "канцлер єднання" Німеччини під тиском партії
мусив скласти з себе повноваження почесного голови ХДС.
Судячи з усього, 1-2 мільйони були верхівкою айсберга.
Пішов з посади також лідер партії і фракції Вольфґанґ Шойбле, близький до Коля.
Тоді ХДС й очолила нинішня канцлерка Анґела Меркель,
яка засудила сумнівні практики в її партії.
Пізніше Шойбле зміг повернутись у велику політику.
Партію оштрафували позбавленням її легальних державних виплат.
Також було зроблено суворішим закон про фінансування партій у ФРН.
Обвинувачення у плагіаті під час написання докторських дисертацій
поховали не одну яскраву кар'єру в останні роки.
Найвідомішим випадком стала відставка міністра оборони
Карла-Теодора цу Ґуттенберґа у 2011 році.
Він був надзвичайно популярним молодим політиком,
якому пророкували стати канцлером Німеччини.
Однак скандал з плагіатом змусив його згорнути амбітні плани та поїхати до США.
За рік громадські активісти знайшли ознаки плагіату в докторській роботі
у міністра освіти Аннете Шаван.
Вона пішла з посади, алеспробувала повернути звання доктора через суд.
Однак їй це не вдалося.
Корупційні скандали найчастіше призводять до відставок політиків у Німеччині.
Втім, у 2009 році міністр транспорту землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія Олівер Віттке
втратив посаду через надто швидку їзду.
Радар зафіксував, як лімузин Віттке їхав по місту зі швидкістю 109 кілометрів на годину.
Це понад удвічі швидше ліміту. Нині Віттке працює депутатом Бундестагу.
Політики у Німеччині ризикують посадами за найдрібнішими корупційними підозрами.
Їм рідко коли вдається вистояти під медійним та громадським тиском.
Чого не скажеш про українських політиків.
Заплутані обставини подорожі Зеленського до Оману,
так само, як відпочинок Порошенка на Мальдівах,
так само як і тіньові оборудки цілої низки високопоставлених чиновників,
не потягнули за собою політичних наслідків.
Низька відповідальність українських політиків вищого рангу за порушення ними законів
- це те, що поки суттєво відрізняє Україну від Німеччини.